a revealing conversation with tony
award-winning actor and best-selling
author alan [ __ ] known for playing
unique and really unforgettable roles on
stage and on screen he has a new memoir
out today in [ __ ] writes about those
roles that have repeatedly in his words
saved him and he spoke with anthony
mason in his first tv interview about
the book at his bar in new york city
it's called club coming anthony good
morning that's right good morning alan
cummings new memoir is called baggage
tales from a fully packed life and we
started with him offering to make me a
cocktail
what can i get you sir the part-time
bartender at this little nightclub on
new york's lower east side is also a
well-known actor when it comes to club
coming i do bartend i love it and people
are like oh my god it's him do you make
strong drinks
yeah
i am a heavy poor
and you might need a strong one
cigarette
reading alan cumming's story you start
this book you're on the verge of
enormous success
but you're
almost falling apart hot mess
yeah were you conscious of it at the
time that was a hot mess yeah yes
if we were to marry
i'm not talking about now i'm talking
about the future
that would tie things up just grand now
don't you think so the scottish actor
was just beginning to get international
notice in films like circle of friends
but he was in the midst of a divorce and
a nervous breakdown after confronting
physical abuse by his father that he'd
long buried when i was 28
i
suddenly remembered all this stuff from
my childhood i was a warped man he
writes in baggage a construct of my
father's violence and my suppression of
it a frankenstein of fear and shame it's
not like you're fully healed from it is
it
no it's still with me you know it's
still i still get triggered by things
and we all have
baggage we all have trauma it's like a a
jenga piece you can't pretend it's not
there otherwise everything will fall
down one of cumming's darkest moments
was the day he auditioned for the james
bond film goldeneye it was one of the
worst days of my life actually really i
felt really really
really low and i just actually now think
gosh you poor little thing you couldn't
you didn't even you could have said i am
feeling
you know
suicidal
today and were you feeling that yes
yes i am invincible but somehow he got
the part of bad guy boris grishenko that
was something i realized when i was
writing the book oh my god all these
hollywood saved me from the you know i
was in the situation and suddenly like
hello it's hollywood come over here now
and go all right and off i go yeah i
have a sort of mantra which is cancel
continue
and i think you know when something bad
happens i think that's it's okay that
happened we can't change that let's move
on they weren't the kind of people you'd
like to fool around with
if you know what i mean
he moved on to a small but memorable
role in stanley kubrick's final film
eyes wide shut not a clue
[Music]
and played a film director stalking the
spice girl the camera
is the window to the soul in spice world
i learned the spice girls dance moves
from the spice girls themselves and just
had an absolute gas but his experience
playing the superhero nightcrawler in x2
x-men united wasn't so super i was
really miserable whilst making director
brian singer he writes created a culture
of conflict on the set throwing tantrums
hiding in his trailer he's behaving like
an actor supposed to
the cast including halle berry hugh
jackman and patrick stewart all still in
costume staged an intervention with the
director in cummings trailer and we
finished and then we heard and alan and
harley speak for all of us brian and
that was patrick and this is so not his
voice it was hilarious and didn't go
well the intervention no no i didn't no
it did not
and you know
angry out of control men
uh are obviously very triggering for
someone who grew up with an angry out of
control father yeah and you shouldn't
have to put it over there don't have to
that's too short yeah council continue
okay
[Music]
i didn't realize
you initially turned down cabaret
yes
i know i was such a little
snobby brat
i didn't think of myself as a musical
theater person i kind of still do it
[Music]
but as the master of ceremonies in the
1998 broadway revival he would take home
the tony oh gosh thank you so much you
were quite literally the toast of the
town yes
yes like in like in a huge way and it
was incredible
the new york observer crowned him the
frolicky pansexual sex symbol for the
new millennium
and the scottish actor decided to stay
near broadway new york became home for
you yeah i was celebrated for many of
the things that were not seen as
positives when i lived in london yeah my
scottishness
my
weirdness my sexuality
bartender club owner actor and author
alan [ __ ] is understandably called
eclectic
do you need to move around for some
reason
well yes otherwise i'd fall over
and also talking of like moving around
i'm going to do a solo dance piece next
year really you know yeah i'm going to
have to move around in that because it's
just me on stage but you were so
insecure about your dancing yes yes i'm
doing a dance piece
i just you know i'm i'm i contain
multitudes
[Laughter]
he sure does that that that dance piece
he's doing he's going to play the
scottish poet robert burns starts out in
edinburgh that comes to the joyce
theater here in new york i can't wait to
see it we should say we reached out to
brian singer for comment about the
allegations surrounding the filming of
x-men united we have not heard back one
thing for certain alan [ __ ] after
that experience decided he didn't want
to ever be in that position again he's
never made another superhero film
interesting which is interesting and i
got to say i gotta also say if you if
you want to see a brilliant alan coming
performance that's four minutes long his
only scene in eyes wide shut with tom
cruise is extraordinary look it up on
youtube i made a mental note of it for
sure
it's amazing what people can be going
through and are capable of hiding it
from the world right he's in a great
example yeah it seems like his light is
so bright but at some point it was dim
and nobody knew yeah 28 years for that
to come back up can you imagine you
suddenly realize it was when he was
thinking about having a child himself
but suddenly he recalled what he'd been
through as a child and that's one reason
he's never had children cancel continue
i like that yep i got matra a lot
anthony thank you